not
slithering eh are you sure
you could be great you know it's all
here
in your head and slytherin will help you
on the way to greatness there's no doubt
about that
no well if you're sure
better be
[Music]
today we have another incredible lesson
for you
with harry potter by the way in case
you're new here did you know that
every week we make lessons just like
this one
to help you learn fast native english
without getting lost without missing the
jokes
and without subtitles take bruner
from brazil for instance she says that
her english has improved a lot and that
we make
really fun and interesting classes so if
you want to learn in this way
join our community of over 4 million
learners
by hitting that subscribe button and the
bell down below so that you don't miss
any of our new lessons
[Music]
welcome to hogwarts now in a few moments
you will pass through these doors and
join your classmates but before you can
take your seats
you must be sorted into your houses
they are gryffindor hufflepuff
ravenclaw and slytherin
now while you're here your house will be
like your family
your triumphs will earn you points any
rule breaking
and you will lose points
at the end of the year the house with
the most points
is awarded the house cup
sorry the sorting ceremony will begin
momentarily
[Music]
welcome to hogwarts now in a few moments
you will pass through these doors
and join your classmates mate is a
common word in britain and australia
it literally means friend but it can
also be used as a general way to address
other people
you can often use it at the end of other
words to refer to the person with whom
you do a particular activity
take a look at some words that are
associated with mate
a housemate or flatmate is a person who
shares the house with you
a roommate is a person who shares a room
with you
a teammate is a person who plays on the
same team as you
a workmate is a person who works at the
same place as you
consequently classmates are the people
who are in the same class as you
at school or university
no you heard me correctly mr malfoy you
see honorable as your intentions well
you too were out of bed
after hours you will join your
classmates in detention
but before you can take your seats you
must be sorted
into your houses to take a seat
literally means to sit down
it implies that there's a place reserved
for you it's also possible to say
find or get a seat when you are looking
for a place to sit
now if you don't want to spend a lot of
time looking for a place to sit in the
cinema or at a concert
you can ask someone to save you a seat
it means they'll reserve and prevent
anyone else from sitting in your place
we got lost
then perhaps a map i trust you don't
need one to find your seats
but before you can take your seats you
must be sorted
into your houses to sort something means
to organize
categorize or separate it into specific
groups
for example i always sort my laundry
into colors and whites before washing
them
sorts can also be used to refer to a
category of things or type of person
for example wizards from gryffindor are
the courageous sort
you'll soon find out that some wizarding
families are better than others potter
you don't want to go making friends with
the wrong sort
i can help you there
i think i can tell the wrong sort for
myself thanks
they are gryffindor hufflepuff
ravenclaw and slytherin
well you all know of course that
hogwarts was founded
over a thousand years ago by the four
greatest witches and wizards
of the age godric gryffindor
helga hufflepuff rowena ravenclaw
and salazar slytherin as you've seen the
houses in harry potter
are named after four great wizards and
witches who founded hogwarts
and the sorting hat places students into
one of them
according to their abilities and
character
hufflepuff is the house for students
with a strong sense of justice and hard
work
ravenclaw students are intelligent and
creative
its members value intellect and talent
slytherin members are often very
determined resourceful and willing to
bend the rules
harry feared going to slytherin due to
being the house to which his arch enemy
voldemort belonged
gryffindor the house where harry ends up
is known for its members courageous
choices
and loyalty sorting hat was right i
should be in slytherin
it's true harry you possess many of the
qualities that voldemort
himself praises determination
resourcefulness
and if i may say so a certain disregard
for the rules
it is not our abilities that show what
we truly are
it is our choices
if you want proof why you belong in
gryffindor
then i suggest you look more closely
at this
gryffindor to pull that out of the hat
[Music]
to learn more about the harry potter
houses and see in which house you'd best
fit in run
over to our instagram after this lesson
to check out the posts we've made for
you there
how would you like to develop confidence
in your speaking
whilst having real-life conversations at
the touch of a button
when connecting with other learners from
all around the world
sounds like a dream right well now with
the real life app
we've made it a reality you can download
the app
for free and improve your listening and
speaking
whenever and wherever you want just
click the link
in the description down below or you can
simply search for the real life english
app in the google play or apple app
store now
download it now and let us guide you
beyond the classroom to live and learn
and speak english in the real world
your triumphs will earn you points any
rule breaking
and you will lose points earn and lose
our opposite words
antonyms to earn something such as
points money or an award means that
you've acquired it by making an
effort on the other hand to lose
something means failing to win or retain
something you acquired
careful not to confuse it with loose
double o
which means the opposite of tight
he pretended to congratulate the three
brothers on their magic
and said that each had earned a prize
for having been clever enough to evade
him
you're a full harry potter
and you will lose
everything at the end of the year
the house with the most points is
awarded the house cup
cup in competitions is an object similar
to this
given as a prize to the winning team one
of the most famous ones is
fifa's world cup which is a football
competition
in harry potter however students from
the four previously mentioned houses
compete for the house cup
an award given to the one who earned
more points for their academic
achievements
and or bravery assuming that my
calculations are correct i believe
that a change of decoration is in order
gryffindor wins the house cup
the sorting ceremony will begin
momentarily
the sorting ceremony is a ritual
performed at the beginning of every
school year at hogwarts to assign
first-year students to their
corresponding houses
in order to do that one of the
professors places the sorting hat on the
student's head
which will assign based on the learner's
thoughts and personalities to which
house they belong
you may not think i'm pretty but don't
judge on what you
see i'll eat myself if you can find a
smarter hat than me
there's nothing hidden in your head the
sorting hat can't see
so try me on and i will tell you where
you ought to be you might be
long in gryffindor dwell the brave at
heart
they're daring nerve and
when i call your name you will come
forth
i shall place the sorting hat on your
head
and you will be sorted into your houses
hermione granger
oh no okay relax
mental that one i'm telling you
ah right then
right okay good offender
[Applause]
draco malfoy
slytherin
that's not which wizard who went bad it
wasn't in slytherin
harry potter
[Music]
hmm difficult very difficult
plenty of courage i see not a bad mind
either
there's talent oh yes and a thirst
to prove yourself but where to
put you not slytherin
not slytherin not slithering eh
are you sure you could be great you know
it's all here in your head
and slytherin will help you on the way
to greatness there's no doubt about that
no please well if you're sure
better be gryffindor
[Music]
when i call your name you will come
forth
what does come forth mean in this
context
to move forward to make an appearance
to reveal the truth
[Music]
although come forth here means literally
taking a step
forward this phrase also means making an
appearance or to reveal the truth
in different contexts however if you say
that something goes
back and forth it means that it is
repeatedly moving from a place in one
direction
to the opposite one well young for a job
aren't you
i'm actually looking at apartments mary
margaret's place will be crowded after
the baby
and i'll be back and forth from regina's
but emma she can't sleep in her car
i shall place the sorting hat on your
head
and you will be sorted into your houses
here shall means the same as will so
this sentence is exactly the same as
i will place this sorting hat on your
head note that this is quite an
old-fashioned use of the word
a more common use is with the question
shall we
at the end of a sentence to make a
suggestion or to ask if someone is ready
to do something
dobby is free
[Music]
you lost me my servant
you shall not harm harry potter
[Music]
expecto
hermione granger
oh no okay relax
mental that one i'm telling you
mental is a british slang term for crazy
in order for harry to believe him ron
says i'm telling you
this is an expression used to emphasize
that what you said is true
you could also say i can tell you or i
tell you
alert the order if you can are you
mental we're going with you it's too
dangerous
are those muggles in their
rightful place
i'll tell you she's starting to freak
out a bit
slytherin
that's not which wizard who went bad it
wasn't in slytherin
in the harry potter world wizards are
anyone with magical powers while
ordinary people are called muggles
at least somebody took care of the nomad
what
the no match no magic
the non-wizard oh sorry we call them
muggles
you wiped his memory right if some food
drink or fruit goes bad it means it's
spoiled
and can't be consumed anymore note if
you say that someone has gone bad
it means that this person started to
behave in a bad
mean or evil way and is probably doing
things that are against the law
first and understand this harry because
it's very important
all wizards are good some of them go bad
a few years ago
there was one wizard that went as bad as
you can go and his name
was his name was
hmm difficult very
difficult plenty of courage i see
which is not a synonym of plenty
harry potter is full of courage harry
potter has a great deal of courage
harry potter lacks courage
[Music]
take a look it's supposed to be your
area of expertise clearly
it's full of dark magic i seriously
doubt it's severus
not a bad mind either there's talent
oh yes and a thirst to prove yourself
but where to put you did you notice how
the word
either was pronounced this is one of the
words
most brits and americans pronounce
differently
most brits would say either and most
americans would say it as
either however nowadays people just
choose whichever pronunciation they feel
comfortable saying
they are both correct can you identify
which other words from this list would
pronounce differently
tomato tomato
neither neither
[Music]
mobile mobile
vitamin vitamin
schedule schedule
and the first to prove yourself
but where to put you to have a thirst
for something
means to have a strong desire or need
for that thing
for example kids have a thirst for
hands-on outdoor activities
you could be great to know it's all here
in your head
and slytherin will help you on the way
to greatness there's no doubt about that
greatness is the property possessed by
something or someone of outstanding
importance
in other words you could use it when
something or someone has a high status
and or lots of importance and it's often
admired by many people for example
superheroes are the symbol of greatness
most humans aspire to
dobby has heard of your greatness sir
but never has he been asked to sit down
by a wizard like an equal
[Music]
and slytherin will help you on the way
to greatness there's no doubt about that
in this sentence there are two words
which contain
silent letters they are letters we write
in words but that we don't actually
pronounce
can you identify them it says no doubt
about that
in this sentence the word there has a
silent
r so what you hear is there
the other one is doubt which has a
silent
b so it's pronounced doubt
if you want to learn more about silent
letters we'll soon publish a lesson on
this topic on our other channel real
life english
so subscribe to it so you don't miss out
on that lesson
also before you watch the scenes without
subtitles and answer some quiz questions
i want to let you know that you can
learn english with us
every day on all our channels podcasts
and on instagram
[Music]
welcome to hogwarts now in a few moments
you will pass through these doors
and join your classmates but before you
can take your seats you must be sorted
into your houses
[Music]
come on up take his needs i told him he
seemed to be worth waiting for
i was beginning to worry you had lost
your way
come we've saved you a seat
come on jenny we'll get you a seat hurry
[Music]
they are gryffindor hufflepuff
ravenclaw and slytherin
now while you're here your house will be
like your family
your triumphs will earn you points any
rule breaking
and you will lose points
at the end of the year the house with
the most points is awarded
the house couple
sorry the sorting ceremony will begin
momentarily
when i call your name you will come
forth
i shall place the sorting hat on your
head
and you will be sorted into your houses
hermione granger
[Music]
oh no okay relax
mentor that one i'm telling you which
word is not
a synonym of mental nuts
mad witty
ah right then
right okay good offender
[Applause]
draco malfoy
[Music]
slytherin
that's not which wizard who went bad it
wasn't in slytherin
harry potter
[Music]
hmm difficult very
difficult plenty of courage i see
not a bad mind either there's talent
oh yes and a thirst to prove
yourself to have a thirst for something
means
to want something very much to need to
drink some water
to feel the need to hurt someone
but where to put you not
slytherin not slytherin not slytherin
eh are you sure you could be great you
know
it's all here in your head
and slytherin will help you on the way
to greatness there's no doubt about that
no please well if you're sure
better be gryffindor
your day brings new opportunities
and i was ready to make a statement
[Music]
how does the saying go